foreign
[Music]
and I'm an assistant professor in the
department of pharmacology at the
University of North Carolina at Chapel
Hill I'd like to start off by thanking
the organizers for inviting me to speak
today and I'm excited to share some of
our science with you
today I'm going to be speaking to you
about inhibiting the raspathway as a
treatment approach for pancreatic cancer
I wanted to start with a brief
introduction to this pathway there are
three rafts isoforms k-ras and Ras and
hras
as a family these mutations
mutations in these proteins Drive about
25 percent of human cancers
K Ross is mutated primarily in
pancreatic cancer and that will be the
topic of our discussion today
the pathway Downstream of k-ras that I
will focus on is the Wrath Mech ERC
pathway
some of the cancers with the highest
frequencies of rasputations are
pancreatic colorectal and lung
adenocarcinoma
and when we look at cancer-associated
deaths in the U.S these three cancers
are at the top of the list therefore it
is there is clearly a clinical need to
Target this pathway
pancreatic cancer has the highest
frequency of Ras mutations
therefore our lab is interested in
targeting the RAS pathway for pancreatic
cancer treatment
and because compounds that bind directly
to rafts have been hard to develop we
have focused our efforts on targeting
Pathways Downstream of brass many of
which are pictured here
however if you follow the field you may
be thinking to yourself that we actually
do have direct Ras Inhibitors now and
this is true so the rasive the first Ras
inhibitor was approved by the FDA in
June 2021. however this inhibitor and
others that have been developed
specifically Target mutant wrasse in
which the hot spot glycine 12 has been
mutated to a cysteine
while k-rash g12c mutations make up 14
of the rasmutations in all human cancers
this frequency comes primarily from long
adenocarcinoma where 30 percent of
patients Harbor a rasputation and of
those 30 52 percent are k-ras g12c
mutations
unfortunately only two percent of k-ras
mutations in pdac are g12c mutations
therefore for this particular cancer our
best bet is still targeting the pathways
that are Downstream of brass
so today I'm going to begin my talk by
discussing some published work on how
three of these strategies Converge on
the process of autophagy
then I'm going to transition into ways
that we are endeavoring to improve dual
Earth Map kinase and autophagy
inhibition for pancreatic cancer
treatment
is now well accepted that mutant k-ras
Alters the metabolic state of pdac
mutant k-ras has been linked to
upregulated glycolysis differential
channeling of glutamine intermediates
and glycolytic intermediates and it's
also been associated with a differential
utilization of nutrient Scavenging
Pathways primarily autophagy and macro
penocytosis
today I am going to focus on the
metabolic process of autophagy which is
literally cellular self-eating during
times of nutrient stress
autophagy has been implicating it has
been implicated in sustaining the
tumorogenic growth of pancreatic cancer
pancreatic cancer primary tumors and
cell lines have elevated autophagy under
basal conditions
and inhibition of the autophagy pathway
either genetically or pharmacologically
has been shown to cause tumor regression
and prolonged survival and pancreatic
cancers uni grass and genetic Mouse
models of pdac
this is this was the state of the field
when I entered it in about 2014.
coming from a Ras lab
we had a very simple initial hypothesis
because so many pancreatic cancers are
driven by rasputations and because
autophagy is of regulated in pancreatic
cancer we started with the very simple
hypothesis that kras is what was driving
the high levels of autophagy in pdac and
our first experiment was to Simply knock
down k-ras with a hypothesis that we
would see a loss in autophagy
however what we observed was the exact
opposite we actually saw that silencing
of KRS increases glycolytic flux
I'm going to be using this autophagy
reporter system a lot throughout my talk
so I'm just going to take a few seconds
here to describe it
what we're over expressing in the cells
is an M cherry and egfp tagged lc3b
while this construct is localized the
autophagosome both the M cherry and egfp
fluorescence is observable
however when the autophagus Zone fuses
with the lysosome there's a quenching of
the egfp fluorescence and you're left
with a with just the M Sherry
fluorescence
therefore you can read out a ratio of M
Cherry to egfp to read out autophagic
flux a higher ratio meaning faster flux
through the pathway
so as I mentioned the first thing we did
was we knocked down k-ras and I'm
showing here that following genetic
silencing in a panel of pancreatic
cancer cell lines we saw increase in
autophagic flux when we genetically
science k-ras
we do have one k rash g12c model
available in terms of cell lines and
when we treated the Mia pocket 2 cells
with the k-rash g12c inhibitor we also
saw an increase in autophagic flux
and finally using an inducible k-ras
Mouse model developed by the depino
group we were able to show that loss of
k-ras in these in these in cell lines
derived from this mouse model increased
autophagic flux as well
however as I mentioned we do not have uh
k-ras Inhibitors that can be used for
many pdac patients so therefore we
looked further Downstream in the pathway
at a node that could be targeted and so
what we focused on was ERC inhibition
and here what I'm doing is showing you
that erk inhibition phenocopies k-ras
loss in that it increases autophagic
flux in both our panel of human pdac
lines as well as this inducible mouse
model
so therefore we quickly disproved our
original hypothesis but this observation
that erk inhibition or k-ras loss led to
an increase in autophagic flux
made us hypothesize that perhaps the
cells were becoming more dependent on
autophagy in this state
and therefore that concurrent inhibition
of both Arc and autophagy may be a good
treatment strategy
and summarizing a lot of work I'm going
to tell you that this is indeed a
synergistic relationship looking first
at human cell lines we showed that the
addition of an autophagy inhibitor
chloroquine shifted the dose response
curve to an erk inhibitor
we observe this in a panel of pdax cell
lines across a range of different Arc
inhibitor concentrations
reading using combination index as an
indicator of synergy we see a
synergistic relationship across a broad
range of concentrations
we transition these studies into
organoid models and the Synergy was
maintained
and we no matter what node of the
pathway we inhibited whether it be irk
or Mech or wrath we continue to see a
Synergy between Earth Map kinase
inhibition and autophagy inhibition with
chloroquine
finally when we extended these studies
into PDX Drive Mouse Model A pdac again
we saw that tumor weights were decreased
with the combination more so than with
each either agent alone and survival was
enhanced
at the time that we published these
results
um we co-published with another group
that had focused on Mech inhibition
whereas we had focused on Earth
inhibition
and another paper came out the same
month focused on rap inhibition all
three papers showing that inhibition of
each node of the map kinase pathway
synergized with uh autophagy inhibition
and this has led to somewhat of a
Resurgence in interest in autophagy and
ambition as a pdac treatment
this is being tested in a variety of
clinical trials right now some led by
the by the first author of The Companion
paper that came out with ours and we're
very pleased to be involved in in two of
these trials as well one of which is
being performed here at UNC a
combination of Earth inhibition with
autophagy inhibition
so while we're very eager to see the
outcome of these trials we still know
that there is much to be improved with
this combination and therefore the focus
of my lab right now is understanding
ways in which we can improve upon dual
map kinase and autophagy inhibition
so the first
um story that I'd like to tell you about
it today is a way that we so we're
interested in identifying new or
additional sensitizers to autophagy
inhibition
or identifying better autophagy
Inhibitors so the first story that I'm
going to be talking about today is
focusing on additional sensitizers
to to address this question we performed
a crispr cas9 screen using a library
Loosely regarded as the druggable genome
so this encompasses about 2200 genes
that we have therapeutic agents against
and we perform this screen in the
presence and absence of the autophagy
inhibitor chloroquine with the idea
being that we would identify additional
sensitizers to chloroquine treatment
we use the magic analysis package to
quantify our sgrna abundancies for each
gene at the end of the screen and then
we perform gsea analysis to rank
um
to rank the magic beta scores
we identified the the Hallmark mtor C1
Gene set among the most significantly
depleted Gene sets and this was an a
comforting result to observe as others
have shown that mtor inhibition enhances
metabolic Reliance on autophagy
we've found that multiple genes within
the mtor pathway were depleted in
chloroquine treated cells and one of the
major one of the most depleted genes
that we observed was the igf receptor
as an orthogonal approach to
characterizing the effect of chloroquine
tree treatment on pdac cells we also
sought to characterize the signaling
changes that accompany chloroquine
treatment by reverse phase protein array
or rppa analyzes
these can be thought of as a large
Western blot where we can look at the
signaling status of about 250 different
proteins all at once
so these are some of our top hits
consistent with the mechanism of
chloroquine prohibiting autophagosome
degradation chloroquine treatment caused
a dramatic increase in the autophagosome
associated lc3b protein as well as the
lysosomal protein lamp two this was a
comforting control to see
interestingly
chloroquine treatment also caused a
market increase in phosphorylation and
activation of receptor tyrosine kinases
including the igf receptor
when we utilized our crispr screening
data to investigate whether the loss of
any of these rtks or other signaling
proteins were sensitizers we found that
the igf receptor to be selective in that
it was both a hidden our crispr screen
as well as upregulated in the rppa
analysis
and we were able to validate this result
in house so you're looking here at a
western blot and you can see that a
punk-chloroquine treatment we see an
upregulation in the phosphorylated state
of the igf receptor whereas we don't see
changes in total igf receptor
to validate this result We performed
dose response studies in the presence of
an igf receptor inhibitor as well as
chloroquine
so you see the IDF receptor dose
response across the bottom and then
we're stepping in different
concentrations of chloroquine and again
this was also a synergistic relationship
we also observe that treatment with an
igf receptor inhibitor led to an
increase in autophagic flux not to the
same degree as what we observed with erk
inhibition but to a significant degree
and then in collaboration with Stephen
hursting's lab here at UNC We performed
uh
a mouse model study in in which we
looked at the combination of chloroquine
and our igf receptor inhibitor and saw a
significant decrease in tumor growth in
the Dual treated mice
however while this while this change was
significant
statistically we still had
fairly large tumors remaining in the
combination treatment
therefore we went about trying to
understand how we could further push the
Reliance of igf receptor inhibited cells
on autophagy
to do this we selected a panel of 11
clinically relevant Inhibitors and also
included Inhibitors that were previously
established to modulate autophagy
we then performed a small-scale
fluorescence-based assay that utilized
our pdax cells over expressing our
autophagy reporter construct and we use
flow cytometry to monitor autophagic
flux
so what we're looking at here is the
effect of each of these Inhibitors alone
and then when we layer on the igf
receptor inhibitor
and what you can see is Mech and irk
Inhibitors stand out as agents that can
further
um induce autophagy when combined with
an igf receptor inhibitor
and that's Quantified here here you can
see a direct comparison of the igf
receptor inhibitor in Orange to the to
an erk inhibitor in blue
so you can see that while an erk
inhibitor can induce more autophagic
flux than an igf receptor inhibitor the
combination treatment shown in purple
here has the highest level of autophagic
flux induced so igf receptor inhibition
can further enhance autophagy in an erk
inhibitor state
looking at Upstream signaling primarily
phosphorylated ampk you can see that
both igf receptor inhibition alone and
erkin addition alone cause an increase
in phosphorylated ampk but it's the
combination that can drive an even
greater increase at a range of different
concentrations
interestingly we also show that this
combination was more cytotoxic so here
I'm showing spheroid assays we're
reading out apoptosis the The Matrix is
of an erk inhibitor and igf receptor
inhibitor and you can see the panels of
minus and plus chloroquine and
appreciate that there is more cell tox
fluorescence when we add on chloroquine
to this combination
this is reproduced in a number of
different pancreatic cancer cell lines
and finally we move these studies into
organoid cultures and showed again that
the triple combination of Earth
inhibition igf receptor inhibition and
chloroquine dramatically reduced pdac
organoid growth
and so therefore we in we conclude that
the addition of an igf receptor
inhibitor further potentiates the Earth
chloroquine combo
moving forward we're interested in
further validating this combo in more in
Vivo models
this triple combination I should say in
in Vivo models
and then we're also interested in the
dramatic up regulation of rtk signaling
in general upon chloroquine treatment
when when cells are treated with
chloroquine there is a large increase of
autophagosomes in the cell
and we know that the receptor tyrosine
kinases are endocytosis following
activation and some literature suggest
that they can that these receptor
tyrosine kinases are still capable of
signaling from endosomes
and therefore we're interested in
determining whether receptor tyrosine
kinases are capable of signaling from
internalized structures following
fluoroquine treatment
the last thing I'd like to talk to you
about to you
the last thing I would like to speak
about today is our efforts to identify
better Inhibitors of the autophagy
pathway
so hydroxychloroquine is not a
particularly potent autophagy inhibitor
and it's not specific to the autophagic
pathway
and therefore we hypothesize that if we
could determine a better way to more
potently inhibit this pathway the
combination in general would behave
would be more durable
so going back to our druggable genome
crispr screen
and focusing now on our DMSO treated
cells while this library was not
designed to be focused on the autophagy
pathway there were a number of autophagy
related genes
that happen to be part of this Library
approximately 70. and of the 70
autophagy related genes roughly half of
them hit as sensitizers in the screen
and that um just further enforces the
finding of others that pdac is reliant
on autophagy for growth
we were particularly interested in this
lipid kinase pick five and that's what
we're going to be talking about for the
rest of the talk
focusing a little bit more on the
details of the autophagy pathway
everything chloroquine which we've spent
most of this talk focused on is a
general inhibitor of the ability of the
lysosome to fuse with autophagosomes
and therefore an end of the pathway
inhibitor however there are a variety of
different Upstream events that can also
be targeted I won't have time to talk
about these today but this is another
focus of our Laboratory
so autophagy is initiated upon all
kindness activation in the form of this
green initiation complex shown here
and then this activates a nucleation
complex shown in blue
and that forms an isolation membrane and
this is where lc3 which we've discussed
earlier gets incorporated into the
autophagosome as it forms and eventually
the autophagosome fuses with the
lysosome and then this is what causes
degradation and recycling of materials
pick five
can be inhibited by the compound a
pillow mod and working with springworks
Therapeutics we became interested in
understanding the effects of a pillow
mod on the autophagy pathway
so just a little bit of background on
pick five
pick five is a lipid kinase that's
responsible for converting pi3p to pi35
P2 is through this enzyme that pi35p2 is
made this is the gatekeeping enzyme for
making pi35 P2
while it's appreciated that mitochondria
fuse and and Fizz quite dynamically in
the cell you may not know that lysosomes
actually do the same thing so they're
very Dynamic organelles and they can
both fuse together and then also
separate and pick five is important for
this ability of lysosomes to separate so
therefore when Pick 5 is inhibited
lysosomes will become enlarged in the
cell
also interesting
to us as a potential Target for cancer
treatment Pick 5 is not an essential
Gene as defined by depth map
so it would not be a generally toxic
Target
when we when we treat our pdac cells
with a pic-5 inhibitor we observe a very
dramatic phenotype as you might expect
from that last cartoon
so as the cells are treated with
increasing concentration of this pic-5
inhibitor of pilomon we start to see
this large vacuolization of the cells
which is very evident here in the 300
nanomolar and what these what these
vacuoles are are these enlarged
lysosomes
interestingly the appearance of these
vacuoles in the cell correlates
perfectly with the GI 50 for a pillowmon
we also see that inhibition of Pick 5
results in an inhibition of autophagy so
what we're looking at here are some
common markers of autophagy
p62 is a general cargo protein and we've
talked about lc3b the cytosolic form of
this protein is lc3b1 and lc3b2 is the
autophagosome associated isoform
so what I'm showing you here is
following 24 hours of a pillow mod
treatment we see both an accumulation of
p62 and an accumulation of lc3b2
across our dose response of Pick 5
inhibitor this this inhibition is
maintained following days of treatment
actually so here the inhibitor is
replenished every three to four days and
we see that autophagy is still robustly
inhibited at these longer time points
so while we are interested in
identifying additional autophagy
Inhibitors we certainly feel that for
pancreatic cancer treatment we will
always have to pair an autophagy
inhibitor with a map kinase inhibitor
so we next decided to determine whether
or not we would see Synergy between a
map arcmap kinase inhibitor and a pic-5
inhibitor so here we're looking at the
mech inhibitor the Met nib and the Pick
5 inhibitor a pillow mod the dose
response for the mech inhibitor is shown
and then each color is an increasing
dose of a pillow mod
and you can see here that we see a
dramatic shift in the GI 50 when we're
treating with increasing doses of a
pillow mod and we're quantifying Synergy
Below in the heat Maps using Bliss red
being a synergistic interaction
so you can see across a variety of pdac
cell lines across a large Matrix of
concentrations we see a synergistic
relationship between Mech inhibition and
a pillow mod and treatment
this relationship is maintained when we
move from our 2D cell culture models to
our organoid models here we see dramatic
Synergy in our organoid models as well
so while because Pick 5 has such a
dramatic effect on cellular morphology
we were somewhat concerned about
toxicity of this
so therefore we looked at the effect of
Pick 5 inhibition on our non-transformed
pancreatic normal pancreatic cancer cell
lines hpne of course they have to be
somewhat transformed to use in culture
but they're the most normal model that
we have
as you can see here in in blue we do not
see a dramatic effect of a pillow mod
treatment on the growth of the hpne
cells
we have HP and E cells that are
transformed with just the RAs oncogene
and you can see that upon transformation
with Ras we do see a shift in the curve
and this makes us believe that perhaps
this will be specific to our transformed
cancer cases
one of the reasons we were particularly
excited about this result is this is not
something that we typically see with map
kinase inhibitor so here you can see an
erk inhibitor is quite toxic to both HP
e and HP e rast cells and the same is
true generally to Mech Inhibitors
however we do see the largest separation
that we've observed to date using near
dementinib more so than what we see with
trimetham
which at least at this point makes us
quite pleased at the potential
therapeutic window for this combination
one of the last points that I'd like to
tell you about is that the combination
of
um ercmap kinase Inhibitors with Pick 5
Inhibitors appears to be a more
apoptotic combination
so I'm showing you in the next m550
assay here and you can appreciate that
both Mech and pick five inhibition does
not induce a large amount of apoptosis
however when you look at the combination
of the two then you start seeing a
dramatic increase in the levels of a of
apoptotic cells
and this is maintained in multiple cell
lines
and when we compare this to the results
that we've had in the past with
chloroquine you can see that whereas we
do see somewhat of an increase in
apoptosis and the chloroquine treated
cells so those are the ones towards the
the far right of the graphs the
combination of pick five Inhibitors with
Mech Inhibitors is a much more apoptotic
combination
so we're very interested in trying to
understand why this is the case
and we have some preliminary data that's
starting to shed some light on this what
we did was We performed an apoptosis
array
in DMSO tree itself each agent alone and
then the combination
and what we observe is a loss of
anti-apoptotic proteins in the
combination treatment
additionally we see an increase in p27
Kip with the combination more so than
either either agent alone and this is
indicative of a G1 arrest and so we're
currently looking
more in depth into the effects of this
combination on the cell cycle
so what I've shown you in this part of
the talk is that pick five inhibition
inhibits autophagic flocks and it also
synergizes with Mech inhibition
and moving forward we're interested in
further characterizing these
differential effects of pick five
inhibition and chloroquine and so one of
the ways that we've gone about doing
this is to submit samples for rppa
analysis in collaboration with chip
petricoin at George Mason University
and therefore by casting this wide net
we hope to observe
which pathways are differentially
regulated
we're also interested in moving our
validation of this combination from
organoids now into in Vivo Mouse models
of pdac as well
so the main conclusions that I've
presented to you today is first our
original observation that erkemount
kinase inhibition causes pancreatic
cancer cells to become addicted to
autophagy and that this combination is a
potential therapeutic approach for k-ras
mutant pdac we furthered this story
quite recently by showing that igf
receptor inhibition further
um
further induces Burke inhibitor cells
Reliance on autophagy and this triple
combination is more potently cytotoxic
in pdac
and then finally looking at different
ways to inhibit the autophagy pathway I
have presented Pick 5 is a potential
Target and shown that this autophagy
inhibition strategy also synergizes with
Earth Map kinase inhibition
with that I'd like to acknowledge the
people who do all the work so this is my
my lab the pick five story that I
presented is the pro one of the projects
from my first graduate student Jonathan
deliberty and he's been helped quite a
bit by our technician Noah Pieper and
running Yang our organoid specialist
the igf receptor story was driven by a
postdoc in Channing dura's lab they're
right next door Clint stahlnecker and
I'd also like to acknowledge my other
collaborators in funding thank you so
much for your attention today